Speaker 1: Let's go to David
from Philadelphia. David from
Philadelphia, What's going on today?
Speaker 4: All right, David. Doing worry.
I know you don't. I don't do that. Sorry.
I. Do you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Okay, cool, cool, cool.
First of all, I just want to say I
listen to that whole Deshaun thing. I
disagree with everything he's saying.
He's full of it. He's just like you live your
life the way you want. You know, if you identify
as a woman, it makes no nevermind. And maybe
you identify as a man. Makes no, never mind me
there. So anyway, I keep hearing you talk about
how conservatives and baggers, they only subscribe
to their principles when it's convenient for
them and drop it once a day and can be correct.
Speaker 1: Right? Well, with
some. With some principles, yes.
Speaker 4: I'd say all of them when it comes
to, you know, when it comes to capitalism,
free market or with free speech or with
limited government. Like all of them, you know,
once it's inconvenient, they drop it. Okay.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, with a lot of those
issues, you're absolutely right.
Speaker 4: You know, so
if we take that to its conclusion, would you say
the only principle these magazines are consistent
with is a white supremacist patriarchy where rich
old white men are on top and everybody else and
everything else is exploited, exiled or eliminated
while the rich old white men just consolidate
and get as much power and money as possible.
Speaker 1: Listen, that's absolutely the case
for some parts of the American right wing, but not
for all of it. And I don't think we gain anything
or advance our cause by painting the entire modern
American right wing as a white supremacy with a
white supremacist brush. So I think you're correct
that the vast majority of the white supremacists
who want to put white Christian men at the top
of a hierarchy are voting more for Republicans
than Democrats that I agree with. But saying
that that's what the Republican Party, what the
entire right wing is at this point, I don't think
it's productive, nor is it completely accurate.
Speaker 4: Okay, I, I appreciate that. Also, let
me apologize for sounding a little pretentious.
I've been doing a thousand things at once and I'm
just trying to get all this out there. So it kind
of sounds a little, I don't know, combative.
Speaker 1: You did a great show.
Speaker 4: Thank you. I appreciate that. I
watch your show all or listen to your show
all the time. And you're one of the better or one
of the better podcasters out there. You're very,
very pragmatic. You believe in one thing, but
you understand the reality of the situation.
And I appreciate that. And not the not the
young Turks are Barron College cousins,
but they're very, you know, why isn't this
the way it's supposed to be? And I appreciate
that you understand why stuff isn't the way
it's supposed to be, even though you wish
stuff would be the way it would be that way.
Speaker 1: All right, David from Philadelphia,
very much appreciate the call. Let's take
a very quick break. If you're holding on,
hold on, because we're going right
back to the phones in a moment.